une crise sanitaire qui prend de
l'ampleur et des médecins en grève au
pérou la fédération médicale a appelé à
manifester devant le siège du ministère
de la santé pour réclamer une
amélioration des conditions de travail
des médecins et des professionnels de la
santé
excédés par le manque de moyens les
organisateurs de ce mouvement pointe du
doigt le problème du budget nous sommes
tous unis dans cette protestation contre
le non respect des règles par le
gouvernement il n'a pas respecté
l'augmentation du budget nous avons
actuellement le budget de plus bas
d'amérique latine
il ne représente même pas 50 % de la
moyenne latino américaine avec un
système de santé fragile et inégalitaire
le pérou tente tout de même de résister
à l'augmentation du nombre de cas de
kobe de 19 mais avec des moyens
fortement limité tous nos services sont
complètement saturé de patients qui ont
besoin de soin et nous ne pouvons pas
les aider car nous avons un certain
nombre de lacunes et de pénurie qui
mérite une attention particulière parce
que nous n'avons pas reçu un budget
suffisant pour cette année pour soigner
les patients avec dignité
nous avons de nombreuses lacunes
notamment le monde d'équipements de
protection individuelle le manque de
médicaments et le manque d espace pour
hospitaliser nos passions qui ont besoin
de nos soins
déjà en mai dernier lors de la première
vague les hôpitaux de la capitale
péruvienne semblait être au bord de la
rupture
le pérou est le cinquième pays
d'amérique latine le plus touché
derrière le brésil la colombie
l'argentine et le mexique d'après
l'université johns hopkins le pays
aurait enregistré plus d'un million de
contamination depuis le début de la
pandémie et avoisine les quarante mille
morts
face à cela lim a récemment décidé de
prolonger la suspension des vols en
provenance d'europe jusqu'au 21 janvier